[Musique]
alors dans le piton FARC c'est un petit
cône que vous voyez c'est du riz parc
cette idée je l'ai eu il y a 20 ans
c'est une inspiration sicilienne et j'en
ai fait vraiment un produit créole nous
sommes deux avec ma fille
lid qui est mon associé maintenant quand
j'ai gagné le Prix culinaire avec innova
tropique on a foncé avec mon mari mon
mari dit oui faut faut y aller donc mais
seul c'était pas évident pour reproduire
ça c'était pas évident donc j'en ai fait
peur à ma fille et puis comme elle avait
l'intention de venir revenir à la
Réunion
elle pourquoi pas maman elle m'a
rejoint ben notre point fort c'est
vraiment le côté innovant piton
FARC alors J'aide ma mère principalement
à la production et également à la
commercialisation des petits pyons
fartis travaill en famille c'est pas
toujours évident mais en même temps il y
a également bah une confiance qu'on
aurait peut-être pas avec n'importe qui
il y a les habitudes qui s'installent on
est plutôt
complémentaire et la conception la
création du pyon Farcy est pour moi un
atout en lui-même Paris que c'est un
produit dont on est fier un produit
innovant et bon le challenge des
créateurs c'est un concours important
pour nous
puisquil y a quand même une une somme à
la clé qui n'est pas négligeable et qui
nous permettrait d'investir dans du
matériel dans l'aménagement d'un nouveau
local qu'on souhaiterait
[Musique]
acquérir j'ai fait de l'animation
j'étais aussi secrétaire et 10 années
médiatrice sociale et puis à mes heures
perdu bien auteur compositeur c'est je
fais des chansons pour les enfants pour
tout vous dire j'ai fait 10 ans de
social et j'ai saturé quoi et cette idée
mon mari d'ailleurs qu' l'a eu il y a 2
ans de ça il dit pourquoi pas l'idée des
pythons voilà on s'est lancé il m'a
[Musique]
suivi j'ai pas comment vous dire ça je
suis pas dans l'entreprise je suis
moralementelle mérite elle a fait
tellement de chose dans sa vie que elle
faisait beaucoup de choses mais ça
marchait pas et là c'est là quandme là
c'est un trucon voit quandme bien parti
donc elle mérite elle mérite largement
parce que de travailler à force de faire
des choses à for de faire des choses
pour les gens que ça ça pas marché parce
que pas été correct et là ce qu'elle
fait
là tout bien tu vois bien c'est pas
possible qu' perde quoi c'est pas
[Musique]
possible et si on gagne le challenge des
créateur ça pourrait peut-être nous
permettre d'avoir notre propre fin de
vente et aussi de trouver dans les rayon
surgelé pourquoi pas participe au prix
du public votez pour votre candidat
favori jusqu'au 27 novembre sur
ww.cg974.fr et la page facebook
challenge des
créateurs
[Musique]